welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to men and black International is a
soft reboot of the franchise that but
better always tried to reinvigorate the
franchise with the new cast of
characters and locales throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the ending
of the film as well as giving my
thoughts on it this is full spoilers
ahead so if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video I hope you
enjoy it now sit back relax and let's
get into my breakdown and I might be
international the majority of men in
black ink Nacional is pretty
straightforward it's your typical affair
that we've come to expect from the
franchise with the world being on the
brink of destruction yada yada yada
by the film's end agents H and M have
finally been caught up with by the two
alien twins that be trying to track them
down for the majority of the film
however in a last-minute turn of events
they are shot from behind in the film's
finale we learned that the true threat
this entire time has been high T played
by Liam Neeson who is actually just an
offshoot of the big villainous alien the
hive the heirs earlier the hive absorbed
high tea and has used him to infiltrate
the British branch of the organization
there was a huge outcry for Neeson to be
cut from the pod after remarks that he
made however it's pretty clear why this
couldn't be done as he is massively
integral to the movies and internet
cancellations only tend to last two
weeks anyway
so I doubt anyone still cares this of
course all ties back to two years
earlier when T and H not to be confused
with age from line of duty who just so
happened to look like Liam Neeson who
plays T oh just get so confusing stop
the hive from destroying the earth on
the surface it seemed like both managed
to do this and throughout the
organization they're regarded as heroes
however the events or rather as H
remembers them played out very
differently in
during the fight tea was absorbed and
H's memories were erased so that he
never thought anything was off from
inside MIB International high tea not to
be confused with mr. t has been creating
a weapon capable of destroying the world
once a brawl after taking the weapon
from hmm not to be confused with the
shop age in M T travels to the Eiffel
Tower revealing his truly terrifying
form and activates a wormhole that will
allow the rest of the hive to come to
earth
hmm tried to stop this from happening
after discovering that the tower is
actually a gateway for all
extraterrestrial life but they're pretty
easily beaten by T though pony comes in
and saves hmm who used the weapon to
distract and kill the hive in the end H
is promoted to head of the bridge branch
and M is fully allowed into the service
and sent home back to MIB and why the to
go on a road trip together with poorni
and you get the feeling that they may be
going on another venture very soon
probably in the Marvel movies though
because this film is bombing critically
right now going forward though if there
is a sequel I can see the two doing a
franchise first and possibly traveling
to space whilst the four films in the
franchise have all taken place on earth
there isn't really a reason for the NY
agent to team up with the head of the
Bridge branch unless something big is
called for it would definitely add an
extra dimension to the franchise and I
would love to see this play out in
future films as the series definitely
needs to do something different to stop
it being stale now is this movie as bad
as everyone is saying well I don't think
so it's nothing out of the ordinary and
by no means does it live up to the
original movie but it's still some fun
to be had here this is a kid's film and
wilds that shouldn't really be an excuse
for phoning it in it's not going after
Oscars and this is simply trying to
inject some new blood into the universe
overall I did have fun with the film and
whilst Atun has been a pretty bad month
for movies so far I don't think that the
blame could be put on MIB shoulders in
the end this is probably the second best
entry in the series and I kind of want
to see more from the two down the line
that's why it gets a 7 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and what you took from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my break
turn of the Avengers endgame timeline
which would be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]